my attitude as a scientist is um i don't
believe any of our theories
i take them very very seriously i study
them i look at their implications but
none of them are the gospel they're just
the latest ideas that we have and you
know so
the reason i study evolutionary game
theory is because that's the best tool
we have
right now in this area
there's there isn't nothing else that
competes and so as a scientist it's my
responsibility to take the best tools
and see what they mean
and the same thing the physicists are
doing they're taking the best tools and
looking at what what they entail
but i don't i i think that
science now has enough experience to
realize that we should not
believe our theories in the sense that
we've now arrived
in 1890 it was a lot of physicists
thought we'd arrived they were
discouraging um bright young
students from going into physics because
it was all done and that's precisely the
wrong attitude yeah forever it's the
wrong attitude forever
the attitude we should have is i uh a
century from now
they'll be looking at us and laughing at
what we didn't know and we just have to
assume that that's going to be the case
uh just just know that everything that
we think is so brilliant right now
our final theory a century from now
they'll look at us like we look at the
physicists of 1890 and go how could they
have been so dumb yeah so so i don't
want to make that mistake so so i'm not
doctornaire about
any of our current scientific theories i
am dr nir about
this
we should use the best tools we have
right now
with with humility well
so let me ask you about game theory
there's um i love game theory uh
evolutionary game theory
um but i'm always suspicious of it um
like economics
um when you construct models
it's too easy to construct things that
over simplify
just
because we our human brains enjoy the
simplification
of constructing a few variables that
somehow represent organisms or represent
people
and running a simulation that then
allows you to build up intuition and it
feels really good because you get can
get some really deep and surprising
intuitions but how do you know
your models aren't the assumptions
underlying your models on some
fundamentally flawed and because of that
your conclusions are fundamentally
flawed so i guess
my question is what are the limits in
your use of game theory evolution game
theory your experience with it what are
the limits of game theory so i've gotten
some pushback from
professional colleagues and friends
who have tried to rerun simulations and
try to i mean the idea that we don't see
the truth is not comfortable and so many
of my colleagues are very interested in
trying to show that we're wrong and so
the idea would be to say that somehow we
did something as you're suggesting maybe
something special that wasn't completely
general
we've got some little special part of
the whole search space and evolutionary
game theory in which this happens to be
true but more generally organisms would
evolve to see the truth so the the best
pushback we've gotten is from a team at
yale
and uh they suggested that um if you use
thousands of payoff functions so we in
our simulations we just used a couple
one or two
because it was the first simulations
right so that would be a limit we had
one or two payoff functions we showed
the result in those
at least for the genetic algorithms and
they said if you have 20 000 of them
then we can find these conditions in
which um
truth seek seeing organisms would be the
ones that that evolved and survived
and so we looked at their simulations
and
and
it certainly is the case that you can
find special cases in which truth can
evolve so when i say it's probability of
zero it doesn't mean it can't happen it
can happen in fact it could happen
infinitely often it's just probability
zero so if probability of zero things
can happen infinitely often
when you say probability of zero you
mean probability close to zero
to be very precise so for example if i
have a unit square
on the plane
and i use a measure in which the um on a
probability measure in which the area of
the region is this probability
then if i draw a curve
in that unit square
it has
measure precisely zero
precisely not approximately precisely
zero and yet it has infinitely many
points
so there's an object that for that
probability measure has probability of
zero and yet there's infinitely
infinitely many points in it so that's
when i what i mean by when i say that
the things that are probability zero can
happen infinitely often in principle
yeah but
infinity
as far as i and i look outside often i
walk around
and look at people i haven't never seen
infinity in real life
that's an interesting
issue i've been looking i've been
looking i had i don't notice it
infinitely small or the infinitely big
and so the tools in mathematics
you could sort of apply the same kind of
criticism that is a very convenient
interface
into a reality that's a big debate in
mathematics the intuitionists versus the
ones who take for example the real
numbers as as as real and that's that's
a fun dis discussion nicholas giessen
has a physicist a really interesting
work recently on how if you go with
intuitionist mathematics
uh
you could effectively
quantize
newton and you find that the newtonian
theory and and quantum theory aren't
that different once you
go with it it's funny it's really quite
interesting so so the the issue you
raise is a very very deep one and one
that i think we should take quite
seriously which is you know
how should we think about the reality of
the contours hierarchy alef 1 aloft ii
and all these
all these different
infinities
versus um
just
um
a more algorithmic approach right so
where it's everything's computable in
some sense everything's finite as big as
you want but but but nevertheless
finite
so yeah that ultimately boils down to
whether
the world
is discreet or continuous in some
general sense
and again we can't really know but
there's just um
a mind-breaking
thought it just common sense reasoning
that something can happen and this yet
probability of it happening is zero
percent
that doesn't that doesn't uh compute for
common sense computer right um this is
where you have to be a sharp
mathematician to really and i'm not
sharp is one word what i'm saying is
common sense computer is
i i mean that uh
[Music]
in a very kind of
in a positive sense
because we've been talking about
perception systems and interfaces
if we were if we are to reason about the
world
we have to use the best interfaces we
got and i'm not exactly sure
uh that game theory
is the best interface we got for this oh
right and applications of mathematics
uh tricks and tools and mathematics the
game theory is the best we got
when we are thinking about the nature of
reality and fitness functions and
evolution period right well that's a
fair rejoinder and i think that um
that was the tool that we used and if if
someone says here's a better
mathematical tool and here's why this is
this mathematical tool better captures
the essence of darwin's idea
john maynard smith didn't quite get it
with evolutionary game theory there's
this better this thing now there are
tools like evolutionary graph theory
which generalize evolutionary game
theory and then there's quantum
game theory so so you can
you can use uh
quantum tools like entanglement for
example as as a resource in games
that that change
the very nature of of the solutions of
the the optimal solutions of the game
theoretic
well the the the work from yale is
really interesting it's a really
interesting challenge of that kind of of
these ideas where okay if you have
a very large number of fitness functions
or let's say you have
a nearly infinite
number of fitness functions or a growing
number of fitness functions what what
kind of interesting things uh start to
emerging uh emerging if you are to be an
organism if to be an organism that
adapts means
having to deal with an ensemble of
fitness functions
right and so we've actually redone some
of our own
work based on those and this is the back
and forth that we expect in science
right and what we found was that they
in their
simulations they were assuming that you
couldn't carve the world up into objects
that uh
and so we said well let's relax that
assumption allow organisms to create
data structures that we might call
objects
and an object would be you take you you
would do hierarchical clustering of your
fitness payoff functions the ones that
have similar shapes if you have 20 000
of them maybe these 50 are all very very
similar so i can take all the perception
action fitness stuff and make that into
a data structure and we'll call that a
unit or an object
and as soon as we did that then all of
their results went away it turned out
they were the special case and that the
the organisms that were allowed to only
see that that were
shaped to see only fitness payoffs were
the ones that were
so so the idea is that objects then
what are objects from an evolutionary
point of view this bottle
we thought that when i saw a bottle it
was because i was seeing a true object
that existed whether or not it was
perceived
evolutionary
theories suggest a different
interpretation i'm seeing a data
structure that is encoding
a convenient way of looking at various
fitness panels i can use this for
drinking
i could use it as a weapon not very good
one i could beat someone with head with
it um if my goal is mating this is
pointless
so i'm seeing for what i'm coding here
is all sorts of
actions and the payoffs that i could get
when i pick up an apple now i'm getting
a different set of actions and pay and
payoffs for when i pick up a rock i'm
getting so for every object what i'm
getting is a different set of payoff
functions
um and act
with various actions and so once you
allow that
then what you find is once once again
that uh truth goes extinct and the
organisms that just get an interface are
the ones that that win
but the question uh just sneaking up on
this is fascinating
from where do fitness functions
originate
what gives birth to the fitness
functions so
if there's a giant black box of that
just keeps giving you fitness functions
what are we trying to optimize you said
that water
has different
um
uses
than
an apple so there's these objects what
are we trying to optimize and why is not
reality a really good generator of
fitness functions
so each theory makes its own assumptions
and says grant me this then i'll explain
that so evolutionary game theory says
grant me fitness payoffs
right and grant me strategies with
payoffs and
i can write down the matrix for if this
strategy interacts with that strategy
these are the payoffs that come up if
you grant me that then i can start to to
explain a lot of things now you can ask
for a deeper question like okay
how does
physics
evolve
biology and where do these fitness
payoffs
come from right
now
that would be that's a completely
different enterprise and of course
evolutionary game theory then would be
not the right tool for that it would
have to be a deeper tool that shows
where evolutionary game theory comes
from
my own take is
that
there's going to be a problem in doing
that
because
space time isn't fundamental
it's just a user interface
and that the distinction that we make
between living and non-living
is not a fundamental distinction
it's an artifact of the limits of our
interface
right so this is a new wrinkle and this
is an important wrinkle
what
it's so nice to take space and time is
fundamental because if something looks
like it's inanimate it's inanimate and
we can just say it's it's not living
now
it's much more complicated
certain things are obviously living i'm
talking with you
there's i'm obviously interacting with
some something that's alive and
unconscious
i think we've let go of the word
obviously in this conversation i think
nothing is obvious this is obvious
that's right
but when we get down to you to like
an ant it's obviously living but i'll
say it it appears to be living it might
get down to a virus now people wonder
and when we get down to you know protons
people say it's not living and and my
attitude is look i have a user interface
the interface is there to hide certain
aspects of reality and others to to
to
it's an uneven representation put it
that way certain things just get
completely hidden
dark matter and dark energy are most of
the energy and matter that's out there
our interface just plain flat out hides
them
the only way we get some hint is because
gravitational things are going wrong
within our
so so most things are outside of our of
our interface the distinction between
living and non-living
is not fundamental it's an artifact of
our interface so if so this is the
if we really
really want to understand where
evolution comes from
to answer the question the deep question
you asked i think the the right way
we're gonna have to do that is to come
up with a deeper theory than space time
in which there may not be the notion of
time
and
show that
whatever this dynamics of that deeper
theory is
and by the way i'll talk about how you
could have dynamics without time but the
the dynamics of this deeper theory when
we project it into
in certain ways then we do get space
time and we get what appears to be
evolution by natural selection so i
would love to see evolution by natural
selection nature red and tooth and claw
people fighting and animals fighting for
resources and a whole bit come out of a
deeper theory in which perhaps it's all
cooperation there's no no limited
resources and so forth but as a result
of projection
you get space and time and as a result
of projection you get nature red and
tooth and claw the appearance of it but
it's all an artifact of the interface i
like this idea
that the line between living and
non-living is very important
because that's that's the thing that
would emerge before you have evolution
the idea of death
so
that seems to be an important component
of natural selection if and if that
emerged because that's also
um
you know asking the question i guess
that i asked where do fitness come
fitness functions come from that's like
asking
the the old meaning of life question
right and so what's the why why
why
and
one of the big underlying lies okay you
can start with evolution on earth but
without living
without life and death without the line
between the living and the dead
you don't have evolution
so what if underneath it there's no such
thing as the living and the dead
there's no
like this concept of an organism period
there's a living organism that's defined
by a volume and space time
that somehow interacts
that over time maintains its integrity
somehow
it has some kind of history it has a
wall of some kind the outside world the
environment and then inside there's an
organism
so you're defining an organism and also
you're defining that organism by the
fact that it can move
and
it can be come alive which you kind of
think of as moving
combined with the fact that it's keeping
itself separate from the environment so
you can point out that thing is living
and then it can also die
that seems to be of all very
powerful components of space-time that
enable you to have something like
natural selection and an evolution
well and there's a lot of interesting
work some of it by collaborators of carl
fristen and others where they
they have um
bayes net kind of stuff that they built
on in
the notion of a markov blanket so you
have some states
within this network that are inside the
blanket then you have the blanket and
then the state's outside the blanket and
the states inside this markov blanket
are conditionally independent of the
states outside the blank blanket
conditioned on the blanket and
what they're what they're looking at is
that the dynamics inside of the states
inside the markel blanket seem to be
trying to estimate properties of the
outside and and react to them in a way
so it seems like you're doing
probabilistic inferences in ways that
might be able to to keep you alive so
there's interesting work going on in in
that direction but but but what i'm
saying is is something slightly
different and that is
like when i when i look at you
all i see is skin hair and eyes right
that's all i see but
i know that there's a deeper reality i
believe that there's a much deeper
reality there's the whole world of your
experiences your thoughts your hopes
your dreams in some sense the face that
i see
is
is just a symbol that i create right and
as soon as i look away that i delete
that symbol but i don't delete you i
don't delete the conscious experience
the the whole world of your so i'm only
deleting an interface symbol
but that interface symbol
is a
portal so to speak
uh
not a
perfect portal but
a genuine portal into your beliefs into
your conscious experiences into
that's why we can have a conversation we
we genuinely but your consciousness is
genuinely affecting mine and mine is
genuinely affecting yours through these
icons which which
i create on the fly i mean i create your
face when i look i delete it i don't
create you your consciousness that's
there all the time um but but i do so
now when i look at a cat i'm creating
something that i still call living and i
still think is conscious when i look at
an ant
i create something that i still would
call living but maybe not conscious when
i look at something i call a virus now
i'm not even sure i would call it living
and when i look at a proton i would say
i don't even think it's not alive at all
it could be
that i'm nevertheless
interacting with something that's just
as conscious as you i'm not saying the
proton is conscious the face that i'm
creating when i look at you that face is
not conscious that face is a data
structure
in me that face isn't it
it's an experience it's not an
experiencer
similarly a proton is is is something
that i create you know when i look or do
a collision in the large hadron collider
or something like that
but what is behind the entity and space
time so i've got this interface and i've
just got this energy that i call a
proton what is the reality behind it
well the physicists are finding these
big big structures amplitude the
sociohedron
what's behind those
could be consciousness
what i'm playing with in which case when
i'm interacting with a proton
i could be interacting with
consciousness again to be very very
clear because it's easy to uh listen i'm
not saying a proton is conscious
just like i'm not saying your face is
conscious your face is a symbol i create
and then delete
as i look and so your face is not
conscious but i know that that face in
my interface the lex friedman face that
i create is an interface symbol that's a
genuine portal into your consciousness
the portal is
less clear for a cat even less clear for
an ant and by the time we get down to a
proton the portal is not clear at all
but that doesn't mean i'm not
interacting with consciousness it just
means my interface gave up
and there's some some deeper reality
that we have to go after so so that so
your question really forces out a big
part of this whole approach that i'm
talking about
so it's this portal and conscious i
wonder why
you can't
your portal is not as good to a cat
to the cast consciousness
than it's a human does it have to be
have to do with the fact that you're
human
and just similar organisms organisms
that similar complexity are able to
create portals
better to each other or is it just as
you get more and more complex you get
better and better portals
well let me answer one one aspect that
i'm more confident about then i'll
speculate on that
why is why is it that the portal is so
bad with protons
well and and elementary particles more
generally so quarks leptons and gluons
and so forth
well the reason for that is because
those are just
symmetries of space-time
more technically they're irreducible
representations of the poincare group of
space-time
so they're just
literally representations
of the data structure of space time that
we're using
so that's why they're not very much
insightful they're they're just almost
entirely tied to the data structure
itself there's there's not much
they're telling you only something about
the data structure not behind the data
structure it's only when we get to
higher levels that we're starting to in
some sense build portals to what's
behind
space time
sure yeah so there's more and more
[Music]
complexity built on top of the
interface of spacetime with the cat so
you can actually build a portal right
yeah right
yeah i this interface of face and hair
and so on
skin
there is some sinking going on between
humans though
where we think like
you're you're getting a pretty good
representation of the ideas in my head
and starting to get a
foggy view
of
my memories in my head even though
you know this is the first time we're
talking you start to project your own
memories you start to solve like
a giant hierarchy of puzzles about a
human
because we're all uh there's a lot of
similarities a lot of it rhymes so you
start to make a lot of inferences you
build up this model
of a person you have a pretty
sophisticated model what's going on
underneath
again i just um i wonder if it's
possible to construct these models about
each other and nevertheless be very
distant from an underlying reality
there's a lot of work on this so there's
some interesting work called signaling
games where they they look at how people
can coordinate and
uh
come to communicate
there's some interesting work that was
done by some colleagues and friends of
mine um
lewis nerens natalia komarova and
kimberly jamison where they
were looking at
evolving
color words so you have a circle of
colors you know this is the color circle
and they
wanted to see if they could get people
to cooperate and how they carved the
color circle up into two units of words
and
so they had a game
theoretic kind of thing that they'd had
people do and what they found was that
when they included so you most people
are trichromats you have three kinds of
cone photoreceptors but there are some a
lot of men seven percent of men have are
dichromates they might be missing the
red cone photoreceptor
they found that the dichromates
had an outsized influence
on the final ways that the whole space
of colors was carved up and labels
attached you needed to be able to
include the dichromats in the
conversation so they had a bigger
influence on how you made the boundaries
of the language i thought that was a
really interesting kind of insight that
there's going to be again a game perhaps
a game where evolutionary or genetic
algorithm kind of thing that goes on in
terms of
learning to communicate in ways
that that are useful
and uh so yeah you can use game theory
to to actually explore that or signaling
games um there's a lot of brilliant work
on that i'm not doing it but there's
work out there
you